As you heard nicely from Jacob, patients at CLL who require treatment are typically presented
two very different options, either a time-limited venetococci-based combination or a single-agent
BTK inhibitor.
This is often a decision based on patient preference, based on risk of certain side
effects, based on comorbidities.
But there hasn't been really a clear standard based on randomized data.
So, I think there was hope that the CLL-17 trial would provide some clarity as far as
a clear standard.
Of course, the reality is that the results may be more alike for both of those arms,
or of course, very similar for both those arms.
So, my goal for this talk is not necessarily to go through all of the data.
This was a very high-visibility trial presented as a plenary session to all of us in the audience.
So, more just to summarize some of the main points to touch on some of the subgroup analyses
and more to kind of present some of my thoughts and discussion on where the trial leads us
in the field next.
So, the study designed that this was a trial conducted mainly in Europe as well as Israel.
Patients were randomized one-to-one into three arms, either single-agent ibrutinib on an ongoing
basis, venetoclax-obinutuzumab for 12 cycles, or venetoclax-ibrutinib for 15 cycles, the
first three of which were lead-in with ibrutinib.
The sample size is based on non-inferiority testing between either of the fixed-duration arms versus
ibrutinib, and the interim analysis that was presented at ASH was planned after 138 progression-free
survival events.
So, that occurred last April, and as you can see here, and as shown earlier by Jacob,
that at that point, which was about three years of follow-up, after about three years of follow-up,
all three of the arms had very similar results of about 80% three-year PFS.
So, the main, I guess, primary endpoint was met that there was a demonstration non-inferiority
between those two fixed-duration arms and ibrutinib.
Of course, kind of looking at the subgroups can be a little bit more interesting and maybe guide
some of the decisions for our patients. For IGHV mutation status, still very similar results for
each of the treatment arms, but perhaps a little bit of separation for the fixed-duration arms,
and that's something we may expect as the unmutated groups tend to have a little bit faster rates of
proliferation and progression. These were not clinically significant differences, maybe
not enough to guide an individual patient to override their preferences, but maybe
information that can be taken into account. For P53 mutation status, there was also some
distinction between the arms, a similar thought process that with P53 mutations, the rate of
proliferation, the rate of relapse would be a little bit faster for fixed-duration treatments.
So, you can see here for the ibrutinib monotherapy, there really is not a distinction in the PFS rate
at the three-year point, but there is starting to be separation for the fixed-duration arms.
I think many of us are somewhat favoring monotherapy with BTK inhibitors for these
patients, although not viewing it as an absolute contraindication for patients that really value
a fixed-duration of treatment. But I think this might be the main group where there starts to
be more separation in two years, four, five, and six. And then fitness, and this to me was a little
bit surprising in that we have this bias that patients who are less fit probably benefit more
from single-agent BTK inhibitors or are more feasibly treated with single-agent BTK inhibitors.
But this is where there was actually a greater difference in the ibrutinib arm, that unfit
patients had a shorter PFS, a relatively shorter PFS compared to fitter patients. This may be that
it was a little bit surprising to me that these entities led to early discontinuation or switching
to other treatments. So, the other, of course, distinction is that these approaches have very
different depth of response. The fixed-duration arms or venetoclax-containing arms had higher
rates of undetectable MRD compared to monotherapy, where undetectable MRD is not an expected endpoint.
For the middle graphs, the venetoclax ibrutinib, this was actually a little bit surprising to me
that these rates were in the 40% range.
For Captivate and for Glow and for Flare, I was used to seeing these numbers more
in the range of the venetoclax-obinituzumab treatment. It may be that the duration of
treatment was slightly different, or I guess we'll learn more over time.
But I guess this is also where we can start to look forward that
if second-generation inhibitors of BTK or BCL2 result in different new MRD rates.
Of course, safety is a consideration, too, and perhaps sometimes the main thing that patients
consider to decide between treatment options. And I kind of summarized it here that for the
venetoclax-containing arms, there was, of course, a higher rate of TLS, although I think these were
all manageable chemical TLS. For the obinituzumab arm, there was a higher rate of serious infections,
including grade 3 COVID and fatal infections, although low-grade infections,
were similar across all three arms. And of course, for the ibrutinib arms, there was a higher rate of
AFib and cardiac disorders or hypertension. With venetoclax-ibrutinib as a fixed duration,
those rates were a little bit lower than the continuous monotherapy with ibrutinib.
So putting this together, where does this lead us? Where does this leave us? And I would say
that I would still view this as kind of confirming the equipoise between the different arms.
And one can say that the fixed duration arms didn't have two less years of treatment to have
the same PFS, so maybe there's value in that. But I think if we look just strictly at remaining
in remission, we can really say that all three of these are the same, that covalent BTK inhibitors
or fixed duration venetoclax combinations have the same rate of at least initial three-year
disease control. Of course, there are obvious questions that with further follow-up, there's
an expectation of separation between these lines. But of course, the opportunity to retreat patients
will probably extend the overall time of venetoclax benefit or venetoclax disease control.
So really comparing the PFS of monotherapy, covalent BTK inhibitor monotherapy,
with the PFS2 of venetoclax combinations will be the meaningful endpoint.
Yeah, as mentioned and alluded to, the secondary-insuring BTK inhibitors may
have better tolerability, longer PFS, and second-generation and non-covalent inhibitors
may look different. And then, of course, there are also second-generation BCL2 inhibitors that
may look different as well. I didn't really touch on this, but there wasn't a planned analysis of
the trial, but we, of course, now are moving to the era of considering between different
venetoclax-obentuzumab or venetoclax-BTK combinations. And I think we might be left with the same kind of
matching a patient to either treatment approach based on their preferences or comorbidities.
So I'll kind of leave us there. Thank you.